as they race to get enough MPS behind
them the Hope Falls in with another
chance at the top drop Penny Morden who
came third last time is the first to
officially declare she wants to be prime
minister but the name looming over this
contest is an old one Boris Johnson is
returning from a Caribbean holiday and
some believe to go forward the party
must go back I would lean towards Boris
Johnson I think he will still have some
questions to answer around obviously
that investigation but I know when I was
safe to fancy invested in defense he
supported me he supported the actions
this country has taken to keep us safe
so that's at the moment I'm leaning
towards that it may have seemed
far-fetched yesterday but Boris Johnson
now has a backing of some very senior
MPS Jacob Rees Morgan Simon Clark
potentially Ben Wallace saying they're
going to back Boris Johnson because this
actually happen could he reach the
threshold I never thought I'd say it but
it's possible and it's partly possible
because we're all talking about it and
that's what Boris loves and that's how
he gains momentum he never really had
more than about sort of 6 6065 core
loyal supporters so the calculation now
will be can they generate enough
momentum firstly to get him past 100 but
more importantly to get him to Second
Place uh you know and I think that's
what they'll be working on this weekend
to try and turn people to make sure that
he does the thing about Boris Johnson is
that there are strong feelings on both
sides some MPS would be incredibly upset
if he came back as prime minister two
have even said that they would quit the
party altogether and remember there's
still a parliamentary committee looking
at whether he misled Parliament but then
there's Rishi sunak and heal is its
strong feelings to some feel Vindicated
by Liz truss becoming prime minister
others say anyone but Rishi sunak what's
clear is there's no obvious Unity
candidate right now
and ultimately MPS most of whom
currently backlashy sunak won't
necessarily get the final say do you
accept if Boris Johnson gets to the
membership he'll likely win I like Boris
Johnson and I supported him to the end
and I wasn't one of those who resigned
from his government but equally I cannot
see how we could unify the party and
bring a government together given that
you know 60 70 percent of his own MPS
were ready to vote against him in a vote
of no confidence or rule yourself out
and then there are The Outsiders the
former Home Secretary understood to
still hold leadership Ambitions in the
international trade secretary Kimmy
badenoff who was taking soundings from
colleagues the party needs to find a
leader to unite behind but the numbers
mean it can only be a three-horse race
penny is the right person to be able to
pull all parts of the Parliamentary
party together to be able to deliver on
what actually matters to our
constituents which is getting that 2019
Manifesto delivered and focusing on
moving our country forward and Penny
having had the range of experience in
ministerial positions over the course of
a 12-year period has the ability to do
that
but at the moment Penny Morden is a long
way from a hundred backers there are two
Front Runners the former prime minister
and the former Chancellor the party
knows it can't afford to get this wrong
again Ali Fortescue Sky News Westminster